you don't have to be in a struggling
punk band screen print your own merch
here's how to whip up some serious swag
at home first off let's talk materials
you're going to need the following blank
silkscreen pre-stretched a squeegee
photo emulsion ink a 150 watt bulb and
painters tape rats and if you want
clamps and a red bulb lamps a black
sheet or fabric or paper gloves and an
apron transparency paper for printing
your image and of course t-shirt or
canvas bag that you want to print
alright step 1
coat the screen with photo emulsion and
make sure to do it evenly on both sides
when exposed to light the emulsion
hardens the image on the transparency
will block light from that part of the
screen so the emulsion can flake off in
the shape of your design leave the
screen to dry in a pitch-black room this
will take a couple hours go ahead and
print your image on the transparency
paper now it's time to set up your rig
play the black sheet over your work area
and blast the 150 watt bulb on the table
now position your transparency on the
screen and let it burn this will take
about 45 minutes once it's burned rinse
with cool water the emotion should flake
off to reveal your image now we print
pour some ink on the screen and use the
squeegee to swipe over it with even
pressure at a 45 degree angle do this
again left to right and up and down over
the image all over the place really but
be careful not to move the screen now
carefully lift the frame and pull out
your swag pretty awesome right repeat as
you see fit
all right look at you you're more than
ready to start your own struggling punk
band